mokhtar jean-michel et gilles sont
partis à la recherche des origines de
l'adar cas et ils ont fait des
rencontres très très surprenante
regardez
[Musique]
les mains puis sandra barca c'est ça
mais déjà mécontentes assez commun lui
sinon quoi tassé et c'est ici cyril a
trouvé son inspiration c'est là qu'il a
eue le c'est tombé sur lui ici syrie je
le dirai serait jamais arrivé au top
s'il était qu'en bo1
on va voir qui va même indice les gars
ustache gh1 poids le voilà le poilu de
la dark assembly séparation quand il n'y
a que des cadavres partout et les drs
cdac les anciens chroniqueurs si c'est
vraiment trop dense pas star wars star
hanouna
[ __ ] ce machin truc de ouf ça sèmerait
redessan [ __ ] isabelle aux allées trop
tard amis ou ennemis
c'est dark vador
vador sarnez modem son cousin
on peut chercher on peut le trouver en
vous suit oui d'accord
[Musique]
réjouissez-vous puzzle game oui c'est
vous qui est à l'origine de puissance de
la barca
[Musique]
quelle langue ils parlent mais c'est pas
que je voulais avoir une chose il faut
domitia travailler mais il a besoin de
poids est ce qu'il veut pour lui donner
de quoi mais il a passé il faut est ce
qu'on voulait connaître la puissance
d'un quart moyens ok mon avis qu'à me
suivre
[Musique]
les garçons bonjour vais vous poser ses
questions si vous n'avez pas au moins
quatre bonnes réponses sur six
vous allez vous faire arracher par
chewbacca ouais ouais ouais
et après vous ne mettrez un peu de
pommade pour nous réconforter non
bonjour même temps que mokhtar si on
remplace les deux leur part des marques
cloud combien de ma clause les films de
star wars et il remporte importés
[Musique]
72 millions ces 40 milliards de
maquereaux 40 min c'était fastoche ici
si vous connaissez rien ne m'est pas
aussi des visites chez jean louis et je
te laisse le temps des huit films star
wars pour améliorer et addiction de
combien de minutes dispose du wifi une
fois trois heures une fois 3 24 24 sont
affirmatifs eu mille sept cent soixante
minutes
bon si gagner gars étaient 1098
non mais on en est pas une non là c'est
une certitude vous allez vous faire
arracher par chewbacca bienvenus c'est
sûr qu'à moi je trouve ça plutôt cool
silicon est bonne idée c'est pas une
question de failles ou pas à une
question tu savais qu'on était ce matin
et arracher les points joe dante avis si
ça reste bridée à ce matin là je mords
emule
allez les gars qu'on a
[Musique]
avec nous
[Applaudissements]